did you know your brain is like modeling
clay constantly reshaping itself based
on what you do this is called
neuroplasticity and it's the key to
rebuilding who you are every thought
word and action hits the record button
on your identity start small read one
page do one push-up write one sentence
these tiny actions rewire your brain
making success automatic but that's just
the beginning your mindset creates your
reality successful people like Steve
Jobs didn't just work hard they created
a reality Distortion field bending what
seemed impossible into reality upgrade
your mental operating system by asking
what can this teach me instead of why me
and here's the game changer time Mastery
your brain doesn't experience time like
a clock it's shaped by events and
emotions match your most important work
to your Peak Energy hours and protect
your focus like it's sacred every
Interruption costs you 23 minutes of
productivity so build an unbreakable
Focus system ready to unlock your
brain's full potential watch the full
video to learn how to rewire your brain
master your time and engineer your
mindset for Success your future self
will thank you